White Collar layoffs are starting to
rise and it's uncertain if this trend
will spread the blue collar industries
as interest rates increase according to
labor department data average layoffs
and finance and insurance uh insurance
industry went from September to November
nearly doubled from a year earlier job
cuts and real estate leasing brokerage
and information also increased by 20
percent and 14 over the same period
however manufacturers Leisure and
hospitality and Retail sectors laid off
fewer workers in the three months
through November compared to a year ago
Blue Collar sectors are less affected by
interest rates but if demand softens
they might hesitate to fire Frontline
workers they struggle to hire and retain
during the pandemic Tom is there
anything to this story we need to be
paying attention to yes there is we were
talking yesterday on the podcast no day
before I certain podcast we talked about
all the stats and the credit card and
you talked about it's just a matter of
time it's a ticking bomb you're just
kicking the can down the road
first of all we have to remember
things in America are mostly
manufactured in China and offshore but
the manufacturing we do have in America
if those consumers slow down blue I so I
agree with the headline Blue Collar
resilience faces a test and the
resilience is going to be the resilience
in consumer spending and whether they're
buying things that are made here in
America and if they're not so a lot of
those blue-collar folks are going to
have um some Challengers there's layoffs
going all over the place you saw Google
laid off 15 and three different uh
divisions uh CFO Ruth poor at really
really sharp she's out there uh what
Google calls other bets laying off
laying off laying off and that's all
because of demand and she's saying it's
demand base they're not seeing the
demand for the other bets that Google's
making so if credit cards and other
thing start reducing demand for physical
things because Google is I.T then yeah I
think Blue Collar halfway through this
year if it's a real recession I think we
should be seeing some of that and I
don't look forward to it it's going to
hurt core America I'll add to that Tom
you know likes to give them more macro
perspective I'll give more the micro
perspective how that affects you as your
life well I want to channel my inner
Warren Buffett you know the one way to
be Recession Proof or inflation proof is
to be the best at your job so we talked
about which teachers should get raises
and which teachers should be fired and
you think that you should fire the
bottom ten twenty percent there's no
question about it no question yeah so if
you suck at your job
probably get fired but if you're great
at your job you're probably going to
keep your job you're probably going to
get a raise and God forbid your company
has layoffs this is going to be a job
waiting for you so at the end of the day
it comes down to personal responsibility
personal accountability personal finance
if you're the [ __ ] at your job not
shitty at your job you're gonna have a
job forever yeah if you suck good
riddance chat chat Ai and start using
the [ __ ] out of it right now exactly
right on term papers for people right be
the local genius this is wonderful thank
you but I think also there's something
what Adam said is you know what maybe
take it easy on discretionary spending
first half of the year maybe they can't
save that money yeah save that money
save the extra few dollars and see how
this is gonna play out you know you you
see those Maps those they call them the
spaghetti maps with all the possible
tracks of a hurricane that's coming
toward Florida or the Gulf Coast right
here in America you should be thinking
of that like you don't know where it's
going to hit but at some point this year
there's going to be a storm what do you
do make sure you've got your coat make
sure you've kind of ease up on the
discretionary spending a little bit and
just and just be ready for whatever
whatever it brings and if it's an easy
year buy yourself a little extra at the
holidays I'm thinking of right now I'm
sorry I went remember there was a
hurricane coming to hit like Florida and
then there was like spaghetti maps and
then Trump like Drew in like marker or
crayon like it could also go here yeah
it's like uh Trump is he just started
trying it yeah I remember this he
completely just like I hope everybody
hurt Adam's point with my follow-up yeah
maybe be prudent this year yeah look out
for yourself and then if the year
doesn't turn out that bad get yourself a
little something nice ultimately what
I'm saying is if there's a wall there
you know just find a way to get over the
wall and just get around that wall it's
so funny draw yourself an extra little
spaghetti cone over there so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]